yo yo yo yo yo yo how you livin how you
feeling how you doing appreciate you
guys you guys have been amazing on
social as always homies 33% stand up
it's your boy the lef koe man and we're
wrapping up sort of our final content
push of everything that was SNL today
two conversations with two guys that are
now Hall of Famers legendary cornerback
from the Patriots Ty Law and arguably
the greatest safety of all time and Reed
we're gonna hear from both of them if
you've been following social you'll see
that I've been sort of asking you guys
what do you want when I come back from
vacation after next week which guests
who should I have so just to kind you
give you behind the curtain we have some
Booker's here one by the name of Dylan
one by the name of Paris and they kind
of go out and say Adam who do you want
to get well I'm kind of turning it over
to you guys who do we need to get who do
we need to talk to active players
coaches really anybody that I can put on
their radar so that we can come back
we're gonna hit the ground running to be
honest man I look I've done a lot of
notes we're still doing the ACL epidemic
we're still doing a left go PR and you
bet your ass we're doing whoa big
offseason but I want to make sure that
we're getting people in here that
interests you so when you see the forms
pop up fill them in left go read it I'm
watching you guys Twitter Instagram as
always you guys are great but let's
start off first with our conversation
with ty long Sims ileft go now joined by
one of the greatest quarterbacks that
this game has ever seen we're talking
five-time Pro Bowls two-time All Pro
three times Super Bowl winner would it
pick six - OH pick six and in one of my
favorite phrases of all time what is it
ah you don't fight the law because the
law will win or you know something like
that I think I butchered my favorite -
Tyler Jordan us ty that's not the phrase
I can't be yeah y'all making me sound
good man stop it that's what we're doing
by two things I'm shocked that I get to
talk to you which is great but I'm also
shocked that you're not not shocked that
you're a finalist for the Hall of Fame
but Sims and I thought you should have
been already but how does it feel for
you being a finalist again oh it feels
great I mean especially when you're
talking about this type of fraternity of
this magnitude and the Pro Football Hall
of Fame understanding that there's a lot
of great players that haven't made it
this far that probably should be and so
I look at it as a compliment I'm honored
to be still in the conversation and what
more could you ask for but you know
being selected and that's up to the guys
in their voting so I look at it as I've
did all I can do out of the field I wish
I can go back out there laces again and
get a few more picks and maybe that'll
put me over but unfortunately that's not
the case so you know the fate lies
within those guys and hopefully they see
me worthy of being in alright tie I mean
hey I got a wax poetically about you I
mean one of the greatest shutdown
corners of our generation maybe the best
defensive player on a Super Bowl dynasty
team that won three out of four Super
Bowls an epic memorable pick six
interception against the greatest show
on turf for Kurt Warner right nobody
gave you a chance and I'll just say I
don't know sometimes I feel like people
forget that you were on that Patriots
team that Richard Seymour was there that
you had all these great defensive
players you know now looking back in
history everybody just talks about oh
it's Brady MD Belichick Brady and
Belichick do you guys ever or you
specifically feel like you're a little
bit forgotten in that conversation
sometimes yeah you feel a little forget
because of the greatness of the New
England Patriots of a sustained period
of time and still right now again in the
AFC Championship on on the doorsteps of
the Super Bowl
it's easy to get lost in the shuffle
because of the greatness that they have
for so long but people need to
understand sometimes and this is just
barbershop tart we in the car we call
right we were a defensive team you know
in a beginning so you know a part of
that dynasty in which we feel good about
his defensive players who were pretty
much the foundation of the team before
Tom Brady became Tom Brady the goat as
he is you know we feel pretty good about
that we for the first three like I said
we were a defensive team you know and we
did what we had to do we we weren't one
of the top defenses in the NFL you know
at the time so and and it gave Tom Brady
the ability to kind of come into his own
before he took the helm and it became
his team so we feel really good about
that I think I'm speaking for the
defense as a whole not just for myself
because I mean we were a complete team
defensively I mean you never know who
was gonna make the next big play same
thing similar to the offense of New
England today you never know whether
it's gonna be wrong element Tom James
white he could have been it can be any
number of guys and that's how we were on
defense cuz we played together I I know
that a big thing for professional
athletes is goal setting so you want to
be a Pro Bowler and you gotta you want
to be a Superbowl champion you got it
was there ever a time even as a kid in a
notebook or as a professional athlete in
a diary that you ever said to yourself
or to anybody else I want to be a
hall-of-famer in this league know I will
be
telling alive if I said I didn't think
about it from a very early on and I
because it's pretty well-documented in
New England so I'm not gonna let it come
back and bite me the but but to be
honest with you I was a little bit you
know more of a hothead in my younger day
and so from day one I said I wanted to
be a hall-of-famer that was my goal
coming in and in the reason that I set
the goals so high wanted to be a
hall-of-famer I knew well not being a
Hall of Famer I had an idea of what it
took to get there so that means you had
to have a sustained excellence for a
long period of time because they don't
just hand those things out and secondly
I had the opportunity to spend my
summers with my uncle down in Dallas
Texas who is also a hall-of-famer in the
Tony Dorsett so I got to be around yes
humble brag so I got to be I got to be
around it I got to be around the
atmosphere and I got to work out with
some of the Cowboys and I admire cuz I
actually I grew up in Pennsylvania alka
Pennsylvania definitely not a Steeler
fan but I was a cowboy fan I always
respected distillers and would they wave
Dukakis especially in the 70s but
everybody was telling fans I was going
with family you know Tony Dorsett from
Aliquippa so you know I really he had a
major major influence on me as far as
wanting to take my game to the next
level not only make it to the NFL but
make a difference you know and live on
through eternity because I got the touch
in the field Heisman Trophy and his Hall
of Fame bus and that had a heavy heavy
info so I was gonna say ty when we're
young and people give us advice we
listen but I don't think it really
registers when you look back what were
the lessons that really stuck for that
long you know for me that the confidence
that he had and ome it's not just what
he did on the field but how he carried
himself you know off the field and the
work that he put in because even towards
the end of his career he was still
working out he was still you know
running I got an opportunity to go see
where I was at as a young high school
9th 10th grade guy you know working out
what Tony Dorsett Eugene la Carque and
Norton jr. you know everything was all
those guys you know we're still getting
it in Natal he was a little bit over the
heel at the time but he was still Tony
Dorsett he's still out there
you know working hard to be the best
that he can be I mean he's accomplished
every single thing that you can
accomplish in college and the pros
Heisman Trophy and college one of the
greatest ever do it same thing in the
NFL but it didn't happen overnight you
know I've heard all the stories you know
because he went to high school with my
mom and dad and how he used to train and
rip it up then you know there's nothing
that he didn't do well but he always
worked on you know the meaning if he was
to happen to beat him at anything let's
go again
so all those type of things rubbed off
on me in the right way you know notice
lower tails and to actually experience
in myself when I was in high school
seems do you know the other NFL players
the big ones that were from Aliquippa
Pennsylvania well Darrelle Revis is the
versus number 24 which is crazy I mean I
mean that's insane
I mean it's Western PA man it's it's a
it's like a foot it's unreal the history
of football there are so many key
players like a Ty Law who are from there
right Sean Gilbert Jonathan first round
draft pick we had some going to later
later rounds as well and you're a team
guy which is like so typical of a New
England guy which I appreciate that's
right look I love to bring it back there
ty because first of all I think the
other thing people need to know about
you as a player because I studied you
and watched you growing up a lot you
were not only an amazing man-to-man
corner you were phenomenal and zone
coverage as well and not all corners can
say that but what did what was it like
you know you had parcels and Belichick
early on in your career you went from
Bill Parcells to Bill Belichick I would
love to hear kind of the changing of the
guard there when Bella cheque took over
and just what it was like to play
defensive back for a Bill Belichick type
defense it was amazing
coach Parcells he made me tougher from
them from the mental side I thought I
was a pretty tough coming from allocable
but there are two different people when
it comes to coaching this strategy you
know coach Parcells is the type of guy
he gets up in your head tell you what
you can't do he challenges you mentally
you know physically to go out there and
beat the man across from you no matter
what coach Coach Belichick is more of an
X's and O's type of guy you can pretty
much count on that he's gonna study more
than you as a player and you know the
most confidence that came with coach
Belichick is when he told me before when
he was a defensive coordinator not the
head coach when he was our defensive
backs coach he said if this guy does
this route he said goddamn it you've got
to sit on him and I said wait a minute I
said well what if he running a hook and
go he was like what happened on me if I
see this if I see this formation and I
see this drop back in this situation
take it and he said I'm not gonna get in
trouble I said oh man this type of coach
I'm talking about right here you know to
me so from there it just was a snowball
into you know building the confidence
you know him as a coach and him building
the confidence in me as a player but I
would be I have to say something about
Pete Carroll because before they before
that transition from coach Parcells and
coach Belichick was on the staff as my
defensive back coach so I had a
different type of relationship with him
because I was with him every day in the
meetings but when Pete Carroll got the
head coaching job from New England
that's when you
my career really you know blossoming I
became one of the top tier of defensive
bats because he had the confidence in me
to let me go out there and match up
man-to-man will gets the best man or
zone with the best receiver on the
opposing side
and then from there it carried on and
that is something that I wanted even
when Coach Belichick was like no we're
gonna do this because me and Bella said
we almost got into a serious fistfight
one time you know jokingly not that far
but you know I was really irritated but
I think it was all in coach Belichick
getting into my head cuz after I think
about it he he kind of let it go too
easy for him to make a meeting saying
that okay Todd this is what we're gonna
do we're gonna put you on Reggie Wayne
and we're gonna we're gonna double mark
I said oh no the hell we not how do we
wear just come from we got to do what's
best for the team we think that you
handed in but we're gonna just take this
guy out because he's a schemer and
things like that and normally you know
you never question coach Belichick but
you know that got to me out like what
you paying me for I said I got scared of
Marvin Harrison you don't mean that put
me on him you know what I may not like
no bill I mean we want to he said okay
but as soon as he beat you
he said we're doing it my way I said
okay I said deal and he never took me
off of you know from from game to game
so and then like say he came up a little
bit too easy but I think he wanted to
see if I was ready to accept that
challenge because you know Reggie Wayne
you know a hall-of-famer and in his own
right but at the time it was Marvin
Harrison Reggie Wayne was number two and
why would you waste me on number two
is so funny ty for the last few years
Sims has been saying that the Patriots
main defensive philosophy is put their
best corner whether it's Revis or
Gilmore although number two take him out
and then double-team the number one so
apparently he was trying to start it
with you but it ain't going for time no
no I wasn't going for that one so but um
but that's just who I was I wanted it
you know it wasn't you know questioning
his you know coaching prowess it was
that I was confident myself and I was
like whoever is on the other side of me
he put his pants on the same way I do I
don't care how many stats he had from
the previous week or how he's done in
his career you know let's go one-on-one
so if we're gonna match up I warned him
if we're gonna play zone I want him to
keep going to the bathroom hell I'm
going to you know so so tie the for Hall
of fans program is putting football's
biggest fans Hall of Fame like it's
literally gonna be down the wing which
is crazy putting fans right alongside of
the players they support it
what do you think about honoring the
fans and was there a certain Patriots
fan that in your mind you lost another
name but just what they look like we're
a memory that was the best Patriots fan
embarrassing you know what all the
Patriots fans are awesome I mean they
come out in droves you know you know
when loser draw and one thing about the
Patriots fans - they're gonna let you
know when they're unhappy even though
they didn't have a lot to be unhappy
about in a long time but I kind of I
definitely respect you know who they are
and how they support the team I mean we
didn't always have one of the nicer
stadiums there was not always a patriot
place and they were there you know what
I mean and they supported me from the
you know time that I showed them I can
play because I heard a few booms when I
got drafted because I wasn't you know
the flashy name coming out in 1995 I won
the flashy names you know but you have
to
earn it around there I don't care what
sport you're in whether it's football
baseball the Red Sox basketball hope the
Celtics Bruins in hockey you have to
earn the respect of the New England fans
and once you do that you know they're
gonna riding down with you and I love
them for that
Ty Law future hall-of-famer
absolute ball array really put that Hall
of fans what you talked about how great
Patriots fans were what do you think
about honoring the fans I think that is
awesome because we wouldn't be who we
are or where we're at if it wasn't for
those fans cheering us on because every
game wasn't a great game every game
wasn't a Hall of Fame game and when you
have fans that stick with you through
thick and thin it's all worth it because
you know we're getting paid you know a
lot of money to go out there and play
win and entertain and you don't always
win you don't always entertain but for
those fans to come out there it was
pretty damn cold in New England now
y'all know that it's cold as a former
player I'm not going to I'm gonna sit in
my house I'm watching on the big stream
I'm here all of the commentary nice and
warm but those fans come out of there no
matter what in the stadium is full and
you have to give it up to the fans the
Patriots wouldn't be the Patriots if it
wasn't for those fans cheering us on you
should see the parades you're in a year
out you would think that you know you
know in no time we've seen the parades
we know thank you very much sighs Thank
You ty the parade not only winning the
game but the parade is one of the
biggest moments for us patriots because
we get to go back out there honor the
fans and talk to him slap high-five get
you know up close and personal with them
and they're out there man and whether
that I can't say if I wasn't a part of
the team I can't say why I would be out
there doing that myself so I give Big
Ups to the fans for for doing that and
continuing to sport
you don't worry you don't have to worry
about the weather tie it inside the
hallowed halls or the Hall of Fame where
your bust will be immortalized for a
long time congratulations good luck Sims
the left goes rooting for you we're
proud about thanks for having beyond
excited what's up it's left go back
again beyond excited that ty law got in
it sucks that he had to wait I'm glad
that the Patriots from that era the
early 2000s are finally getting some
defensive representation in the Hall of
Fame it was not just Brady you've heard
us talk about it a middle a million
times but up next man the man the myth
the legend you've heard the stories over
the years of Ed Reid scaring
quarterbacks and takin balls back 110
yards he's incredible and before he got
into the Hall of Fame he talked to us so
here's our conversation with Ed Reid we
have with us a former defensive player
of the year we have with us the all-time
leader in interception return yards
because he didn't just Hawk the ball he
tried to take it back for a touchdown
and now Sims a finalist for the Pro
Football Hall of Fame and read read ed
man what is this like you're in the
final 15 I bet you it's a little surreal
yeah man you know like I was saying to a
bunch of people man I'm you know I was
never about two accolades you know ago
you know they're there you know so I'm
just kind of taking it day by day and
just soaking it in you know there's a
lot of a lot of people who helped me get
to this point you know so I'm just
soaking it in right now it's literally a
period of your life where you have no
control and it's up to all these other
people but ed you're a thousand percent
one of those guys were the last five
years of your career everyone was
calling you future hall-of-famer and
Reed is it is it weird now that it's
kind of right at your doorstep yeah you
know I mean you know I had an exit plan
you know I had an exit plan to get out
of the NFL as I think guys need to have
you know could you just never know you
know and you know I knew it was gonna
come eventually you know I mean after
this after five years you you start to
get those talks about it you know but
she was like you said five years before
I retired
you know you hand that talk you know so
to be here right now man you know and
getting those phone calls it lets you
know that sooner or later those clear to
be hanging on that line you know that
wire that you used to see back in the
day we use kid throws those cleats over
the line
tie them up and that that's when it's
over did you like you're getting in the
Hall of Fame we know that okay it's just
a matter of matter okay so I guess you
once and you scared the crap out of me
but and we're gonna talk about that in a
second I'm gonna bring you down memory
lane but I do want to know is it extra
special to a guy like Edie Reid arguably
the greatest safety of all time to be a
first-ballot Hall of Famer as compared
to being maybe a second or third year
guy yeah man no doubt you know coming
into the league you know I wanted to be
first round first pick you know I
thought I deserved that but that's
that's just what you shoot for you know
you shoot for the stars
you know first ballot to be to be in
that elite group of Hall of Famers it's
just enough for me just being in that
talk it's enough for me
you know I pray to God that Steve
Atwater gets in you know before he's
voted in and if I if I get in and he
don't get in you know I'd rather give my
space to him you know because I looked
up to Steve Atwater you know but I'm not
the one boy yeah I was gonna say I'd
love to see you champ John Lynch and
like Ty Law get in just be like oh yeah
here's the best secondary from the 2000s
and one fell swoop yeah man I'd feel
your net but like I said man Steve
Atwater is a legend you know I looked up
to
you know to be in that group with him
you know I would give up my space foot
to let him in that thing
wow wow that's that strong okay so why
we're on that topic of like safeties and
great safeties that you admired like if
you had to go back and be the you know
just look at history who was the
safeties you admired growing up and I'd
also like to know other than Atwater I'm
saying and then also who was the guy
like when you were playing that you'd
watch film of and go I got to watch this
guy at safety and see what he's doing
lately like did you have that guy that
you competed with you know in your own
mind nah man I never competed with
anyone but myself honestly to be you
know I was always trying to be my best
be at my optimum maximum level to help
my team win who I looked up to oh man
come on done during that group that era
were you talking ronnie Lott well yeah
yeah God you know I grew up in New
Orleans but we you know our fans had
bags on their heads then you know so
dumb the teams that was that was playing
hard were were were the San Francisco
49ers in them boys you know which I
never liked the boys at all you know so
yeah ronnie Lott was my guy Jerry Rice
you know with his work ethic you know
Walter Payton and I was a huge Michael
Jordan fan you know I played basketball
growing up so his work ethic you know
the classiness about Michael Jordan you
know the things he did on the court high
he pushed his teammates you know I was a
guy who looked up to him and
brought those attributes to football I
think you talk about Ronnie a lot I
would agree with you that he is you know
the most one of the most intimidating
safeties of all time when it comes to
coaches I believe that Bill Belichick is
the greatest coach of all time and I
believe that there are certain players
that he gets obsessed with and watching
Bill Belichick talk about you to me is
like football ecstasy like it's
incredible what what it was it what is
it like for you to hear him talk about
you like that and and do you have a
relationship with Bill at all
I don't man outside of playing against
him and if I ever see him bill has
always been a great motivator to me he
was always like a just do your thing do
you you know I wish I had you on my team
you know I wish I had to play for coach
for at least a year something like that
because you know those type of coaches
you want to play for you know I read
coach Belichick book and admire just the
things he's done how you grew up you
know and his his background of why he
coached the way he coaches and why his
team is so successful the way they're
successful you know it makes a
difference in your environment you know
and I just I mean I really appreciate
you know Coach Belichick the way he
talks about me man way he appreciated my
game you know because there's more than
just wins and losses you know football
football is
it's more than the diamond rings you
know the super bowls and all that stuff
you know Wildcats is one of my favorite
football movies man oh yeah
Wildcats better than a diamond ring
played by a king football yeah I love
new I love that read yeah man that's
buff that's my movie bro so you know it
was it was more about the relationships
in the competition you know enough your
opponents and stuff you went against man
you know I appreciate it you know
playing against all the guys I played
against me out of respect for everybody
you know regardless of their record you
know and things that they were doing and
if you were playing the game it was the
utmost respect that's I mean that's the
one thing okay I'm gonna we know you're
one of the greatest safeties of all time
the one thing I will certainly say you
were the greatest of you are the
greatest past defending safety in the
history of the NFL okay I'm gonna say
that for you and I got to experience it
okay and I just want I mean you you
picked me in our one matchup I don't
know if you remember there was another
play you almost picked me because you
were doing your own thing in the back
end just playing out of position just
trying to get interceptions but that's
where I wanted to go with it ed like
what made or gave you that sixth sense
to have a feel for what the quarterback
did or what the offense was trying to do
I just never feel like you kind of got
the credit for your brains and your
intuition and your feel on the football
field that's what always was so special
man it's funny to me man and people a
lot of people say what you said that I
was doing my own thing you know
let me correct you on that I never yeah
did my own thing that that often like
that like I never just out of nowhere
just so I'm gonna do this to do that no
you were playing cover to and you tried
to take a slant away from me you were
this but you had a reason to you were
right I was trying to throw this when
you were gonna pick us I studied I
studied tape man I I did my homework but
I also understood which a lot of lot of
guys who I talk to now need to
understand you have to understand your
defense you gotta understand I hope is
that you can understand how you can move
in your defense you know I was one of
the first defenders to be moving around
on the football field disguising this
stuff like that and the coaches like
what are you doing and now you see
coaches are actually putting their guys
in certain position and they're moving
them around and but you gotta you gotta
understand how to do that you know not
everybody truly understands on how to
move around and the defense and
understand the opponent at the same time
while having a mind on a play clock and
knowing it down the distance and know
I'm part of the field that they aren't
and understanding what type of plays
that this team like to run out of that
formation that's a lot I just gave you
yeah that's all you can imagine how you
have to just go through that with in a
split second you know like your mind has
to be working on a whole nother level
but you gotta be you got to put the work
in you know as well as I do curse that
you know as a quarterback there's a lot
of information you guys gotta have
there's a lot of information you know
you have to be looking for I mean I'm
talking about
even from tendencies you gotta be
looking at the linebackers to see what
depth they add to see would hold a in to
see if a cornerback is flat-footed or
he's got his foot up cuz he's gonna be
in cover too
or is he playing a man you know is the
Safety's coming dice a lot of
information for a quarterback have to
decipher through I play quarterback
that's a weight did you play quarterback
growing up I played quarterback in high
school
one of my best friends in college was
Ken Dorsey you know he and I ran
practices at the University of Miami you
know so it was a lot there was a lot of
maturation you know to become the player
that I was Curtis Johnson you know who
coached for the for the Saints right now
that's a reason why those receivers are
the way they are you know there's a
reason why Andre Johnson and Reggie
Wayne Santana Moss with the receivers
that they were you know he coached them
in college you know Chuck Pagano was my
my DB coach you know in college you know
so there's a lot of coaches you know
that that we don't talk about that gets
a lot of credit you know coach Davis had
a tremendous coaching staff when I was
at the University of Miami
you know Donnie Henderson and Dennis
Thurman you know and benny andersson
with great coaches when I got to the you
know got to got to Baltimore you know so
there's a lot of coaches man that really
helped me to understand the game you
know to help me take it to another level
and and it was me just you know putting
in the work man watching more tape yeah
I think we just heard part of your
speech thanking a bunch of coaches right
there so all that prepared us but I also
realize I think about all the guys you
play with on Miami but I want to take
you back to like the Oh for Ravens
season because I think there were five
Hall of Famers on that team I think it
would be Ogden and Reed Ray Lewis
Terrell Suggs I think is gonna make is
he will yes you Deon Ray sitting around
did the Hall of Fame even come up
because this is an older Dion where his
life is coming in perspective did you
guys ever talk about the Hall of Fame no
but I mean you know guys mention it like
I said I was never about that stuff man
I I could have cared less you know about
individual accolades you know that stuff
didn't make me you know I wanted my team
to be successful as the reason why I
stayed five years in college I know I
wanted I wanted to win the national
championship that's a team accolade you
know I didn't care about the Thorpe and
all-american stuff that that they had me
up for you know Hall of Fame is its it
you bring your team in there with you
you bring teammates with you you bring
coaches with you but you know I wasn't I
didn't care about that stuff though it
was mentioned you know people who
mentioned that man that that's the stuff
that you know that tend to tend to blind
folk on what they really really can
really really gonna achieve at the same
ad Edie you are the ultimate team player
but when you slip that gold jacket
though that good this ain't a trophy at
a war that's a mess every fighting
nature goes up like two percent this is
when you're back in st. Rose Louise all
right do the spin move when you get it I
just want to see that okay I got to see
the spin move to all right so wait one
other thing I want to bring up because I
know you you don't want to talk to us
all day but you talked about College
okay so we got a like your Miami teams
when you were at the time did you
realize I would argue that your Miami
team that won the national championship
against Nebraska which we screwed up
Texas by the way you didn't want to see
us in the Rose Bowl that year that would
have been a boo a bit different story
Oh nobody
the guy I got these poles that come out
that Texas with Vince Jones the best
team we're to kill them to I bite he was
gonna beat us that year that's the
reason why I stayed in school I was I
was the oldest guy in college football I
was working out at 5:30 in the morning I
was in the best shape of my life it
wasn't happening well we wouldn't have
been there all right I would admit that
you were the better I just said you're
arguably the greatest college team I
ever saw I really would put you guys in
that I do think we would've gave you a
better game than Nebraska I'll say that
much but what point the point being did
you realize how special that Miami team
was though that you're like did you
realize that there was that many stars
on the team even at that age yes I did
yeah that's why I stayed in school you
know I told my stay in school we win the
national championship I'm coming back to
win a national championship I didn't I
didn't stay just to play football and
have fun in college I'm staying to win a
national championship we won a national
championship there wasn't nobody going
to beat us it wasn't happening you know
we might have got some better games but
no no I went to the University of Miami
to win a national championship
you know I understood that college and
NFL was a business you know so I I had
plenty time to play football in the NFL
you know I wasn't worrying about that I
could play football on the moon you know
so it wasn't it wasn't no question that
you know we was gonna win the national
championship there's a reason why you
sitting you know and I don't do this
often you know because a lot of people
always ask me about other people other
players and stuff like that right I was
gonna be sitting here regardless
regardless of all to play with the
Ravens or any other team you know
there's a reason why in high school I'm
considered a hall-of-famer in Louisiana
I'm considered a hall-of-famer in
college football yeah many people gained
not many people can say that on every
level no you were the man at I don't I
mean I still are the man
I remember what I learned about you is
when you stripped up yeah you strip that
boy I do yes you you were amazing and
Irish still remember you stripping that
ball at Boston College that was when I
first all right let's get this together
Matt Walters is 290 pounds he's one of
the strongest guys on the football team
that year
yeah there's no way I'm stripping the
ball out of Matt Walters hand I asked
him Matt for that ball I'm asking Matt
for that but that's the trust we had in
each other that's how much talking as a
safety I did you know communicating to
my guys that's how much we hung out with
each other that we could trust each
other and know each other voice to where
Matt and understood and knew that was me
asking for that ball and he gave it to
me I couldn't take I couldn't take that
ball from a deal I'm not at the
University of Miami it wasn't gonna
happen you know but when there's trust
there that's that's what you get
yeah you can trust that ed Reed is gonna
be getting the Hall of Fame and I'm
pretty sure it's coming right away it's
happening this year now Edie Edie listen
the Ford Hall of fans program they're
putting football's biggest fans into the
Hall of Fame right alongside the players
they supported and I'm curious I think
you don't always know certain fans names
but in Baltimore was there a fan that
pops into your head right now that's
like that was the best fan I ever had
with the Ravens man a fan that pops in
my head you don't need to know their
name but was there one person that was
always there when the plane landed or
one person that was sitting front row or
always had your Jersey on you know what
if I was if I was to break it down to a
fan being that the city supported me so
much man I have to say just the city
the city of the fans you know the fans
in the city you know I can remember when
we lost my AFC championship game we got
back to Baltimore and there at the
facility I mean that at the facility
it's like three or four o'clock in the
morning you know and they're just
showing their appreciation you know I
would have to save my kids that Booker T
Washington man you know for what they go
through you know the joy that they get
if people get in Baltimore from when the
Ravens win a football game and that
meant so much to me to play my hardest
to give my all for that for those people
who go through so much who just get joy
from the simple things of a game you
know who don't have a meal sometimes at
home come on man you know that's what it
was about for me you know such a
blessing to play for those people in
Baltimore or so less fortunate you know
then then we some of us who ever know
sounds like you're you're a fan of Ford
honoring the fans yeah man no doubt
about it
you know I Drive a 350 you know so you
know I hope that forward will come and
do a deal with me it's something like
that for giving them this part you know
I I really appreciate you know ride
around in such a nice vehicle my boy has
an f-150 you know my dad does you know
so I'm a Ford Ford guy you know and as
you can see my career I played 12 years
you know to be a hall-of-famer I was
built that tough
that's awesome Edie Reid is built for
use a man at Donald congratulations on
the appreciated man I'm proud of you man
after all these years you know just
knowing you knowing your dad you know
and you doing your thing man you know
Thanks like keep on going brother
hopefully someday I'm sitting there
standing there next to you doing the
same thing I appreciate the compliment
man you the man I always looked up to
you and I hated playing against you and
you can at least tell your kids i
intercepted the great Chris Simms one
day it was that special I will
definitely tell my son then be well ASEA
man right oh my god take care be good
good luck and Reid is el hombre he is
the man guys if you're listening to this
podcast do me a favor
check me out Friday night 9 o'clock TNT
I'm doing freaking play-by-play of the
Rising Stars game I am putting all my
play-by-play hat something I've really
never done and I'm calling live action
of dudes dunking on each other's heads
it's going to be insane but 33% I need
your help get online go to Twitter add
Adam left go or at Sims and left Co or
Instagram look out for all the docs that
we're gonna have what guests do you want
I've already kind of told you what
segments do you have an idea for what do
we need to do I've never been afraid of
listening to the audience because you
guys know our content probably even
better than a lot of people that work at
the companies that I work at and you
know what you want so for me get in
there do not be afraid there is no
suggestion dumb there is no one too
small or too big we can try everything
I'm just gonna let you guys on a little
bit excuse me I'm gonna get to stick to
football guys on in March they're gonna
kind of download all their information
and I
kind of picked our brains and figure out
who are gonna be team left go who's
gonna be the rookies that I fall in love
with and get super excited about anybody
any any guy out there whether it's an
Evan Silva or I see a lot of you guys
talking about Brett Coleman Dan Orlovsky
whoever you think would be good to have
on I'm gonna go out and get them we get
the Booker's we got the time and I think
it's gonna be awesome
I am the lef koe always appreciate you
saying that your head we will holler at
you enjoy next week there will be no
pods take some time maybe relax like
myself get the brain focused and we are
coming back at the end of February on a
mission and it is gonna be an absolute
cutthroat mission love y'all y'all are
the [ __ ] holler at you a little bit